the United States has unveiled its
latest stealth bomber at a ceremony in
California the multi-million dollar
aircraft is the first U.S strategic
bomber to be produced in three decades
and is being unveiled at a time of
heightened tensions with Russia and
China
[Music]
on its newest deadly weapon
the manufacturer says its stealth bomber
is designed to fly without a crew carry
nuclear as well as Conventional Weapons
evade the most sophisticated radar
systems and hit any Target anywhere in
the world the B-21 Raider was unveiled
during a carefully choreographed
ceremony in California that included
dramatic music a light show and a crowd
of top U.S officials
the B-21 Raider is the first strategic
bomber in more than three decades
it is a testament to America's enduring
advantages
in Ingenuity and innovation
it's also meant as a deterrent at a time
of heightened tensions with Russia and
China the Pentagon says Beijing has
doubled its number of nuclear warheads
and is on track to have 1500 nuclear
weapons by 2035. many more than
originally anticipated and produced much
faster
they will operate in tomorrow's high-end
threat environment and it will enable
America to outmaneuver to outpace and to
outmatch our adversaries it will deter
aggression
the B-21 is expected to cost nearly 700
million US dollars per plane Air Force
officials say it will form the backbone
of its future bomber force and the first
one is expected to be in the skies as
early as next year
[Applause]
let's welcome Joel Hickman in Washington
D.C he's a fellow with the transatlantic
defense and security program at the
center for European policy analysis Joel
Hickman what do you make of the timing
of the new bombers unveiling reveal
well thank you uh for having me
um I think we've got to recognize that
the B21 has been in development since
2015 and we know that both China and
Russia have their own stealth bomber
equivalents and a continuing to work on
these but I think most classified weapon
programs are usually shrouded in secrecy
and we know that the B-21
radar is not going to undertake its
first flight until well into next year
so I think we can read read something
into the timing of this of this
unveiling I think it sends a very strong
deterrence message uh given the current
year political context you know with
Putin's saber rattling in Ukraine and as
mentioned at the top of the program
China's expansion of its nuclear forces
I think this is a strong powerful
message by the United States showing
that both to both of those countries
that it's continues to have military and
Technical technical Supremacy in
uh really high-end military capabilities
we heard military uh top brass there
saying the D21 Raider will deter
aggression but might some see it as a
sign itself of aggression
well I think weapon systems such such as
these do demonstrate to tevin's Value
um again as we said at the top of the
program the B-21 is capable of evading
the most sophisticated defenses it can
carry both conventional and nuclear
payloads it has Global reach it's future
proofed in terms of being able to
incorporate updates and upgrades very
easily
um but I think you know the message to
adversaries is the US has these
capabilities uh that you can't
necessarily defend against so so be
careful how you proceed I mean that is
the whole the whole point of deterrence
um is to have a set of uh weapons and
capabilities which deter uh aggression
so in that sense I think um it serves
its its function but of course the
reality is that there's a whole host of
emerging and disruptive Technologies out
there which the US NATO China and Russia
are all developing simultaneously yes
the B21 can can evade their defenses
through stealth but the Chinese motions
have Hypersonic missiles which can evade
the most advanced air defenses through
through speed
um there's also other weapons programs
from space enabled energy weapons high
power lasers cyber uh quantum computers
autonomous drones these are all parts of
Modern Warfare uh which hope hopefully
serves to strengthen deterrence between
the great military Powers because with
these new capabilities we are moving
from a conventional military environment
to one that is multi-domain
unable to Target critical uh National
infrastructure across a much broader
Spectrum okay we'll have to enter there
that's a Joel Hickman from the center
for European policy analysis many thanks
thank you very much